on parle et nous sommes en direct avec
francis choisel historien auteur de
comprendre le gaullisme bonsoir francis
choisel merci d'être avec nous à ses
côtés pour la partie plus politique que
éditorialistes arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef revue politique et
parlementaire votre dernier numéro de la
revue politique et parlementaire est
d'ailleurs consacré au général de gaulle
bonsoir arnaud benedetti merci d'être
avec nous alors l'appel du 18 joint que
représente-t-il exactement pour
l'historien que vous êtes francis loisel
pour l'historien comme pour tout le
monde c'est le sait le début de la
résistance mais ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que l'appel ait lieu avant
l'armistice est donc une anticipation
sur l'armistice et tout l'intérêt du de
l'appel du 18 juin ce n'est pas
seulement la résistance la volonté de
poursuivre la guerre c'est bien
l'anticipation dissipation d'armistice
mais ça c'était facile mais surtout
anticipation de la victoire ce que je
veux dire c'est que le l'appel du 18
juin est un acte rationnel quand vous
dites acte rationnel c'est à dire c'est
à dire que dans l'appel du 18 juin il ya
le prévision de la manière dont nous
gagnerions la guerre dont les alliés
dont la france gagne la guerre ce qui
est rationnel aussi une stratégie
derrière cet appel auprès d'une
stratégie ce qu'on oublie souvent en
face qu'est-ce qu'il peut 10 mai selon
le lit dans les mémoires de son fils la
mayral de gaulle avant de partir à
londres de gaulle a fait comme dans un
état major
une étude des rapports de force entre
l'aviation allemande et l'aviation
anglaise pour voir si l'angleterre avait
une chance de gagner la bataille
d'angleterre
et comme il a constaté que l'angleterre
avait les forces nécessaires pour
résister à une attaque allemande il est
parti un an
probablement qu'il avait fait le constat
inverse ils n'auraient ils ne seraient
pas partis à l'eau alors ce qui est un
petit peu cocasse finalement c'est que
cet appel du 18 juin 40 il a été assez
peu entendu à l'époque oui on dit qu'il
a été assez peu entendu mais il ya quand
même beaucoup de témoignages de français
qui ont rejoint le général de gaulle
parce qu'ils ont entendu le l'appel
l'appel en outre a été repris dans
certains journaux de province l'appel on
en a parlé donc vous qui êtes dans les
médias le savez bien le fait d'entendre
en direct n'est pas l'élément majeur par
toujours l'élément majeur de l'impact
d'une prise de parole à la radio ou à la
télévision alors arnaud benedetti sur
l'aspect commémoration enfin plutôt
célébration aujourd'hui
évidemment le président la république
était sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision c'est une étape
incontournable pour un président de la
république
oui c'est un exercice imposé pour deux
raisons si vous voulez pour un chef
d'état et un chef d'état fortiori de la
vème république le général de gaulle par
le coup de poker extraordinaire qui est
celui de l'appel du 18 juin
et puis ensuite par son action durant
toute la guerre et notamment aussi en 44
à partir de 44 et notamment la
nomination des commissaires de la
république dont rétablir la légalité
républicaine sur l'ensemble du
territoire va permettre à la france qui
a été une nation défaite en 1940 de
retrouver son statut international de la
scion qui s'assoient à la table des
vainqueurs donc le général de gaulle des
genres dans un premier temps à restaurer
la puissance de la france
le deuxième aspect qui est lié celui ci
à la nature même du régime de la vème
république c'est qu'il est le fondateur
de la vème république il est le père de
cette constitution qui assure une
stabilité une cote de maille si je puis
dire absolument indispensable au
fonctionnement de la vie politique élu
régime donc tous les présidents de la
et public sont redevables d'une certaine
façon de cette double dette à la fois
haut disons chef de la france libre que
fut le général mais aussi au père des
institutions dans lesquelles chacun de
ses présidents c'est ensuite nous les y
compris celui qui fut le plus critique
souvenons-nous françois mitterrand qui
avait rédigé dans les années 60 ouvrages
particulièrement virulent contre le
fonctionnement des institutions et
contre l'usagé ces expulsions par le
président de république le coup d'état
permanent qui lui même ensuite à
endosser sans aucun complexe labit qui
est l avis du chef de l'état sous la
vème république
alors évidemment à chaque fois c'est
sont les accusations par l'opposition de
récupération dans une tribune à marianne
une vingtaine d'élus de droite ont
dénoncé je cite l'imposture et la
provocation de la récupération du
gaullisme par emmanuel macron mais aussi
par marine le pen c'est un débat qui
revient souvent pourquoi cette tentation
si fréquentes de la récupération quand
on parle de charles de gaulle à arnaud
bénéficie toujours parce qu'il est le
dernier homme politique français qui
finalement appartient à la légende que
ces acquis sont aujourd'hui
incontestable le général de gaulle a été
durant sa carrière durant sa trajectoire
politique l'homme politique qui a été
client même s'il est parvenu à
rassembler il à cliver le monde
politique
il a plutôt rassembler les français et
c'est bien sur cette figure de
rassembleur que chaque homme politique
où chaque femme politiques essayent
d'une certaine manière de ramener à elle
mais la différence fondamentale si vous
voulez entre le général de gaulle les
hommes politiques d'aujourd'hui c'est
que le général de gaulle est le produit
d'une histoire où les marges de
manoeuvre pour les politiques étaient
beaucoup plus grandes qu'elles ne le
sont aujourd'hui où nous vivons dans un
monde extrêmement interdépendants comme
d'ailleurs douleur à boucler également
la crise sanitaire que nous avons
récemment pq donc
in fine et on communie dans une sorte de
monde qui a disparu c'est une forme de
nostalgie qui s'exprime alors a bien
évidemment ensuite il ya encore une fois
tous les acquis qui ont été ceux du
général de gaulle et je pourrais en
citer un très grand nombre
oui on va laisser les historiens aussi
le disons c'est adhésion mémorielle à la
figure alafé général francis choisey la
caisse qui fascine autant pour vous
quand vous voyez effectivement tous ces
hommes politiques aujourd'hui tenter de
récupérer cet héritage de charles de
gaulle ça vous inspire quoi
parce que effectivement il ya peut-être
peu de comparaison à faire avec les
présidents des de la république
en tout cas les précédents et celle
actuelle oui on parle de récupération
mais c'est assez normal
le général de gaulle et et le grand
homme français du xxème siècle on
retrouvait au 19e siècle
même phénomène avec napoléon tout le
monde ça spearhead de napoléon tout le
monde faisait référence à napoléon ou
allan poe pour le général de gaulle
c'est normal c'est cet appel contre la
récupération par emmanuel macron je suis
personnellement pas très mac rogne un
dans chaque corps et tombent d'ici là
s'il avait oublié célébrée le 18 juin
le 18 juin c'est comme c'est comme le 8
mai c'est comme le 11 novembre
maintenant les gars il y à un autre
élément c'est que le gaullisme
on l'a souvent présenté comme étant
l'une des trois droites la suite de rené
rémond mais ça n'est pas l'une des trois
droites en succès la synthèse de tout de
tous les courants de pensée france est
la synthèse entre socialisme et
libéralisme entre londres et les
libertés etc
et dès lors que c'est la synthèse de
tous les courants de pensée politique
chacun des courants politiques chacun
des courants politiques se retrouve en
partie dans le gaullisme peut être à la
fois gaulliste et anti gaulliste
alors il ya ceux qui sont dans la
continuité de la synthèse et qu'il ya
ceux qui sont d'accord avec une partie
du gaullisme dont chacun
légitimement considérer qu'il est dans
la filiation du gaullisme quels qu'ils
soient à l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche au centre mais selon sur une
partie du nord est des ti vous parlez du
charles charles de gaulle et vous dites
pour lui les peuples ont une âme
profonde et leur indépendance ne se
négocie pas c'est quelque chose qui
sonne de manière très actuelle
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs lectures du
gaullisme mais si vous voulez il ya une
première lecture qui consiste à
considérer que le gaullisme c'est une
capacité d'adaptation aux circonstances
et donc le gaullisme ne serait pas une
doctrine figé mais une pratique du
pouvoir en fonction des rapports de
force et en fonction des intérêts de la
nation
c'est cette texture d'ailleurs que font
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'hommes politiques
qui se réclament du gaullisme était il
ya une autre lecture qui consiste quand
même à regarder les textes et ce qu'ils
écrivent et le général de gaulle est en
effet le général de gaulle il avait un
certain nombre de principes qui tombe de
haut et qui sont assez intangible alors
on peut essayer de les triturer au
regard de notre lecture contemporaine
mais il avait un principe qui était un
premier principe était assez assez assez
assez constance était de considérer
d'abord que la démocratie était
indissociable de la souveraineté
nationale il a écrit et il a mis en
pratique
et c'est bien dans ce principe qui fonde
pour une grande partie l'ensemble de son
action
alors il y à aujourd'hui où bagarre
autour de cet héritage et je rejoins ce
qu'il vient d'être dit c'est à dire que
le gaullisme est un mouvement qui
embrasse finalement un ensemble de
courants politiques dans lesquelles
chaque formation politique peut s'y
retrouver pour lui par avec quand même
une petite différence c'est que c'est
quand même mouvement qui est fondée sur
la personnalité du général de gaulle et
le général de gaulle est un homme qui
est d'abord quelqu'un qui pense la
politique à travers la pensée et qui
ensuite la met en action
et c'est vrai sans maman l'une des
caractéristiques
deux sons de son de sa façon d'être dans
le monde dans le monde politique auquel
il n'appartient pas d'ailleurs qui fait
vraiment la différence avec ses
successeurs ensuite très pour terminer
revenons un instant à la seconde guerre
mondiale avec vous français soit l on
dit souvent de de gaulle qu'il avait
l'intelligence de voir plus loin
qu'elles étaient ses relations avec ses
alliés les britanniques les américains
les russes
il y avait des relations d'état à état
car comme cela a été dit tout à l'heure
le général de gaulle n'était pas dans
son esprit à la tête d'un corps de
volontaires ils étaient la france il
était le gouvernement de la france il
était le gouvernement de la république à
l'ombre et donc lorsqu'ils discutaient
avec churchill il était en quelque sorte
encore le secrétaire d'état du
gouvernement paul reynaud puisque de
gaulle n'était pas un général inconnu
il était peut-être pas très connu mais
ça n'est pas un général comme les autres
il était secrétaire d'état à la défense
dans le gouvernement de paul reynaud et
il avait connu il avait discuté avec sur
tille par longtemps mais souvent dans
l'est dans les semaines qui ont précédé
l'armistice donc avec l'angleterre il
avait de nouveau la question comment
comme tout le monde c'est très très
houleuse avec sur tille
mais une relation d'état à état avec
roosevelt la route vers la relation a
été plus tardive
vous allez considérer que la france
avait avait disparu de la scène mondiale
avec la défaite est négligée et la
france en général jouait plutôt la
france officielle les relations entre de
gaulle et russell était mauvaise
pour ce qui est de l'union soviétique de
staline et bien d'autres l'utilisaient
staline comme un contrepoids par rapport
à roosevelt et là encore ils agissaient
d'état à état et soro son objectif était
était d'ailleurs non seulement
d'utiliser staline pour équilibrer
roswell staline cyprès nos s'y prêtant
pas trop mais il voulait surtout que la
france soit présente partout c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y avait des
troupes françaises
enfin il y avait le groupe normandie
niemen l'aviation française sur le front
russe
c'est un élément important que la russie
dont la russie a encore mémoire
aujourd'hui qui était une volonté de de
gaulle de montrer que la france était
présente partout la france a été
présente en erythrée en afrique en
italie de surtout l'élection de bataille
c'était c'était une volonté de montrer
que la france est elle présente partout
même si c'était dans certains endroits
symboliquement ce n'était moins
symboliquement débarquement de provence
puisque c'était la moitié des troupes
s'étaient plus symbolique au début
lorsqu'il s'agit celle de l'erythrée
c'était important que c'était bir hakeim
en libye puisque le rôle de la première
division française libre a été important
pour pour vaincre rebelles voilà sont
pour répondre à votre question les
relations de de gaulle et à des
relations personnelles avec sursis mais
quand même malgré tout des relations
d'état à état non pas de l'intérieur à
google même si francis loisel merci
merci également à vous arnaud benedetti
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour évoquer cet appel du 18 juin
cet anniversaire
aujourd'hui le 80e